what came first for you art or business
it was art man it was both actually like
they came at the same time to be honest
I was fortunate to have a very close
friend of mine ding Israeli who I did my
first like production job with and I was
a I was craft service or something like
that like 19 was this 1995 my first job
once it was craft service and it was for
a very good friend of mine
Daniel's really owns a company called
pop art film Factory and what I learned
from him right off the bat and was that
he was a director when Alan was you the
director he owned the production company
so I learned off the bat like if I'm
going to be in this game I got to be
like my friend Daniel got a own the
company I got a own a production company
and then direct so I learned a business
before directing my year I got set up a
company I said steli entertainment IP i
piayed and in second ad-din first lady
95 into 1996 and working me hi my friend
Daniel being 21 at the time I got
envious of you know I'm like man I want
to be a director he was older than me in
in obviously like a mentor in a way but
he didn't realized that I was actually
paying attention and sucking up
everything and so after 96 I developed
his attitude like y'all want to be
director so I'm like 21 22 talking to my
want to be a music video director and I
was working at Kodak at the time and
like I said being in the shadow of my
friend dings aurelion him kind of
bringing me up the ranks like PA the
second ad dat first lady I was first ad
in like big music video they were on be
et and like 96 and that would kind of
built up my confidence to you know
starts telling entertainment from a
business perspective so I was like if
people want to take me serious I gotta
have a production company and then my
production company will loan out my
directing services or my writing
services or my producer services or
whatever so in my twenties I like right
away how to run a production company
get checks written to stellae
entertainment not to delle stelle II so
that was a big deal for me in a big step
for me and my company because I worked
at a pulse house at the time and I would
take I would take some of my friends out
to lunch and then when I put my credit
card down
it was my stellar entertainment credit
card maybe like how do you got a stellar
entertainment credit card and I was
already started my business was already
doing lunches it was it was bananas
because I had already foreseen me
starting my company I already seen
taking my friends out on lunch meetings
I already see myself buying this car and
seeing my car going on the back lot with
my director place like I didn't
visualize all this and I made it happen
and in like you know two thousand six or
seven I'm going on the backlot of
universal they're letting me in because
they know my car and recognize me like
everything that pre-visualize and
everything came to life can change fly
all the way to me getting the office on
the backlot not even knowing how that
was going to happen but i knew i want to
be on the back lot and i end up on the
back end up on the back lot for like a
year and a half with a partner mine and
but yeah when you believe in and you
have faith and you put that in the
universe every day you can manifest some
unbelievable situations I like to say
like me I don't come from a rich family
I just really dedicated myself in
figuring out this movie business every
facet every from pulse production I
worked in post-production for over 13
years so I know exactly what it takes to
shoot and make a movie for little money
or for you know huge amounts of money
and you know having that talent and
skill I think is is very valuable in
this business because right now with the
technology and everything people are
condensing condensing film crews to
three men four main crews now used to be
20 25 people crew back in a day because
of budgets and technologies in these
Millennials in on
you know how to make pride shapes with
the cellphones and everything so it's
like you really got to stay on top of
the creativity and and and put out the
best product that you can economically
and and you'll win
you